all right we're talking with Zane in
Missouri just graduate from college a
business degree debt-free getting
married and thinking about a buying a
house that's about how far we got in the
conversation so tell me the rest of the
story yeah basically what it is is I've
got the opportunity to buy a house from
my parents it's a house that they've had
as a rental for a while and be honest
with you they last set of renter's
didn't leave it in the greatest shape
and not really wanting to be in the
rental business anymore and I actually
like the house and I've got the gut the
cash to do a remodel to the house
he offered me basically to do like a
rent-to-own through him with no interest
and that I could basically have the
house paid for in six years a little
over six years actually no I was going
to say if it's better to look at the
bank and all the money rather than owe
money to my parents yeah I don't know
yes it is the borrower is slave to the
lender the law of gravity says that when
you jump off a building you will go down
to the sidewalk and there are no
exceptions
now you can have a nice master or you
can have a mean master but you are
always a you are always a slave with a
master when you borrow money 100 percent
of time and so Thanksgiving dinner
tastes differently and it might not be
so much for you as it is it just makes
your new wife feel weird okay because
she owes them money and she took your
mama's baby boy away mm-hmm
and she owes the money it could change
the relationship with between her and
your mother which is already a difficult
relationship by the way okay yeah yeah
so don't do it don't don't do it don't
do it I would you know if you're gonna
do the deal if you're gonna do the deal
do it with non-family debt and I love
the idea you set it up to pay off now my
question is this when I was your age the
mistake I would have made would have
been because this is a bargain
it's a project and it's gonna result in
a nice house after you're finished that
you can make some money on and that's
all you're considering and if I'm you
and I'm your age a hundred percent of
time I would have been over the moon
enthused about this idea
mmm-hmm to the point that I really
wouldn't get to the point that I really
would not have given my wife a chance my
wife to be a chance to speak into this
deal I just would have done it right
don't do that okay make sure that you
make sure that all of the reasons that
you have in your head that this is
awesomeness beyond belief are quieted
and you keep your mouth shut
and you let her actually express what
she thinks of this deal because I'm not
sure it's a good idea to do a rehab in
your first year of marriage it's a good
reason it's a good it's a poor way to
start your marriage right right now I
was actually planning to have it done
prior to us getting no that's good I was
that's good news yeah because we're
married in September and actually
basically what I mean her early decided
we were moving by the house we just
hadn't decided and which now she's
living with me to get married obviously
but we so the big thing is make sure she
makes sure she's on board and she's not
on board because of Zayn's zealous
passion for this deal mm-hmm
make sure she really actually actually
really really really down inside thinks
this is a good idea spoken by a guy who
didn't used to do that very well it took
me about 38 years which is how long
we've been married so I tend to see what
needs to be done and get about the
business of doing it and then I'll ask
your opinion after I'm done and this is
not good relation
ah not a good husband so be a good
husband saying alright numbers